[Music]  president obama has a new video out have  you seen this in which he speaks  directly to the camera and he references  some of the dinners that he has had with  supporters during his campaign and i  watched this video and i have to say i  don't think it was such a good idea for  the obama people to release this during  the last weeks of this campaign there  will be debates speeches and more ants  but if i could sit down with you in your  living room or around the kitchen table  here's what i'd say you are right on the  line between plenty and embarrassing not  too embarrassing you're just the right  amount have you guys take a look at this  menu yep don't forget you guys are on a  date  sweet and you want me to redo your hair  because this is a disaster you know the  truth is that's about as much as i can  take up your heat thanks for listening  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]